what's the point of a game engine if not
to make games
so we made one the very first playable
game by studio cherno a remake of an
arcade classic in this video we're going
to talk about what it was like to make
this game in hazel our in-house game
engine stick around till the end of the
video to see how you could play this
game for yourself and now let's begin
hey what's up guys my name is ashono
today we're going to be looking at a
game that tim made in hazel
you know what you made the game my
hair's gone for some reason why you just
take over those videos falling apart
anyway hey what's up guys my name is not
the churner i'm tim and today i'm going
to be talking to you about how i made
this space invaders clone and hazel my
job is a bit more unique since out of
everybody on the hazel core team i'm the
only one that's not developing the
engine but rather using it to make games
and let me tell you about the fun
experience of doing that but before that
let me tell you a little bit about
myself my name is tim and i study
computer science at university and for
the last eight months i've been working
as an engineer on the hazel team making
games because i'm the only one on the
team doing that not only do i have to
write all the c sharp code that makes
the game run i also had to make all the
art using blender and photoshop before i
started working here i had no digital
art experience i mean just look at this
3d model i made
this is meant to be a spaceship this is
terrible one of the great resources that
helped me learn this quickly was
skillshare skillshare has a bunch of
great classes on these topics and their
photoshop classes in particular are
great and help me learn this quickly
skillshare is an amazing online learning
community with thousands of classes on
pretty much any topic you could think of
from creative ones like art and
photography all the way to business and
marketing they've got it all it's
honestly so easy and inspiring to browse
through skillshare and find an
interesting class and the best part is
they're all concise and high quality
with bite-sized episodes that you can
quickly get through in your downtime
they're also an excellent way to unwind
after a busy day something i really like
using skillshare for with their many
relaxing illustration classes but more
recently this class literally about
plants
you can have a browser yourself for free
the first 1000 people who click the link
in the description of this video and
join skillshare will get a one month
free trial huge thank you to skillshare
as always for sponsoring this video so
once i told you that you were making a
space invaders clone where did you begin
i opened up unity um because you know
everything is easy to do in unity right
i made the game in unity i made a
prototyping unity and from there once i
was comfortable with the process of
making space invaders i took it to hazel
yeah so one of our goals with hazel is
to
try and make the workflow for making a
game as simple as easy as intuitive as
possible and so by making the game first
in unity tim was able to learn about the
workflow of making the game in the first
place and then we could hopefully
improve upon that in hazel as well as
like get some much needed features into
the engine to make that possible exactly
and that's kind of how game engine
development works like the
things that are being made with the
engine drive the development of the
engine itself yeah
exactly and like drawing from my
experience working at ea as well like it
was very common for battlefield for
example to be like okay the direction
for the game is this like we need this
major new destruction like technology
and the frostbite team will be like okay
we're gonna work with you now to kind of
implement that tech so this is actually
kind of similar but on a much smaller
scale yeah yeah so once you have the
prototyping unity what did you do next
so i actually took it to hazel i started
making the game on hazel and as you can
see the first playable commit didn't
even have collision detection it just
had like
bullets being created and shooting up
and like later when collision was added
like they there was destruction of
entities and so on what do you think of
hazel
i like hazel i like hazel not just as a
product but the team that that is
building it i want to say okay so as
opposed to something like unity you were
saying about features in hazel it's good
because you have a link to the engine
team exactly yeah so if something is
missing in the engine uh i can talk to
the churner or peter or like with jay
for example back when i was doing audio
stuff and i'm able to get like support
from the team that's developing the
technology and understands it really
well it merges really well they
understand it perfectly because they're
the ones that developed it
sure beats documentation
that's right yeah which we still don't
have
what happens if hazel doesn't have a
feature you need you just ask for it
yeah that's right so during the course
of development for example prefabs
weren't a thing in hazel
and for a game like space invaders where
there's multiple identical entities
being instantiated essentially they had
to be like
created and the mesh had to be copied
from a
entity that existed in the scene so the
workflow for that was just terrible and
like prefabs was definitely the most
natural solution to this and so for this
game in the middle of development young
introduced the concepts of prefabs to
the
to the hazel
you remind me of those people who are
like
the ukraine
that's literally what i thought of as
well when i said that the hazel so so
what is what's the prefab for those who
don't know
do i know that's that's a good question
do i even know you have to pretend you
know
a prefab is i know you're a paid actor
but
that is genuinely what i had but i
specifically requested an actor who knew
what prefabs were right you might have
to talk to the agency about that one
yeah
so prefab is exactly what it sounds like
it's something that's been
pre-fabricated
prefabs are good for what
prefabs allow us to dynamically
instantiate entities during a game's run
time during a scenes or on time that
like already have component data
hierarchies all of that stuff set up so
prefabs
yeah so prefabs allow you to dynamically
instantiate entities during games
runtime that already has all the
necessary component data
um and that saves you know computational
power during runtime instead of like
adding all these components during
runtime and then wasting like both
script code on that and and
computational power whereas that could
be just saved already i like this
confrontational power
because like well the other thing is i
think that's just wrong because
[Laughter]
it doesn't exactly save computational
power because
like technically
it does it just makes the use the user
like workflow a lot easier
because it allows you to just make
something once like a template and then
spawn it in wherever you want in the
world and it's like already ready to go
because how else would you
you know compose that entity dynamically
during a game like you need to spawn a
bullet it has to be this this material
this script this everything this
collider how would you spawn that like
if you didn't have prefabs you would
have to essentially like
write some code that would create an
entity and set it up and that code would
have to be called every time
well in hazel we got like a lure right
that's what describes a prefab
well you literally don't use lower
we use lure for something yeah for
pre-make
okay
i've seen that somewhere i've seen that
following search for something so
another thing that was added during the
development of this game was dynamic
meshes the workflow prior to this
for example with the shattered alien in
particular the workflow prior to this
was to create 15 different like entities
and like each of them has a mesh
component and then manually create a
hierarchy in hazel but each of those
entities had to be manually exported one
by one from blender and then like
generate a mesh source from that so each
each piece of the shattered mesh was its
own entity that you had to manually set
up
yes
how was that
it was gruesome and gruesome especially
when something went wrong and then you
had to re-export the whole thing like
that was
so now that we have dynamic meshes we
can just import the entire thing at once
exactly yeah like and it's really easy
um one thing that's hopefully coming in
the future is like
multi-entity
editing at the same time for example
at the moment it's still like a
limitation that you have to go on each
one place a script component type of
script name in
in the future we're gonna have a much
easier workflow around that but compared
to what it was back then where it takes
like 30
minutes probably to make one prefab
um it's a lot easier now one thing that
we were missing that's essential to any
game is
loading scenes
imagine having a game where the only
gameplay is the main menu that was kind
of the problem where we were at so we
needed to be able to transition from the
main menu to the gameplay scene or from
the main menu to the settings and vice
versa
and so when we realized this was
implementation of the agent that was
added probably within a day and so
that's the kind of cool and dynamic
environment that like you get to
experience with hazel is because it's a
this isn't a recruitment video all right
so how was like hazel's stability and
crashes and how much work did you lose
a lot
you mean not much
i lost like literally a couple of times
i lost a day's worth of work
more than
once pillow if you see the black mark
like
yeah all right
from the top hazel back in the day had
less memory leaks and so you could work
like a day without you're supposed to
say this thing better
i'm saying how it is back in the day
hazel could run for a long time
without crashing
and
you know i was not in the good practice
of saving my work back then as i am well
practiced now
save after virtually anything and before
playing a scene definitely in case like
the engine crashes on me during one time
cut point is
more than once i've lost a day's worth
of work
like a full day's worth of work that was
back in the terrible measures like that
was that was horrible like
now it's a lot nicer to lose a day of
work that's that's really the goal of
any engine to make it really nice to
lose work would you say that this lost
work has
contributed to a better game because
you've had a second chance at making the
same thing and so you've made it better
i would say it's definitely
formulated me as a better person
throughout the process of this my
patience
and my tolerance has grown and i've just
in general become a nicer person to be
around i'm like less irritated because
of like my work with hazel and the
patients that it's producing
so in summary it's good for a game
engine to not have an undo system or
and also crash yes yes because it makes
you a better person
you know that's it that's all it took to
make the game happen hope you all
enjoyed this new format video the tim
format
just like the rocky game that i made in
an hour you guys can check out that
video up there by the way this will
initially be only released to the
partner tier of my patreon supporters
the full source code and assets we
really want to ship this game like for
free and distribute it to all of you to
play that's the goal but hazel at the
moment just doesn't have a way to
actually like package and ship a game
we're working on that as we speak as
soon as that's ready we'll make it
available to you guys for free yeah
there's plenty of like optimization
packaging other work that needs to be
done to be able to actually ship this
game maybe we'll put together like a
little road to distribution series that
might be fun also big news studio china
is doing latinum day of 50. yep we'll be
live streaming the entire thing doing
the game jam three days all of the
studio tuner which includes peter in
sweden we'll be making a game using
hazel and live streaming all of it thank
you all for watching thank you all for
supporting we'll see you next time
goodbye
[Music]
you